S
UNACCEPTABLE.
AND THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS NEWT GINGRICH,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF "FEEDING BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM, WROTE.
I WANT TO GET INTO THE NEW
AMERICAN MAJORITY.
BUT THIS IDEA OF NATIONALIZING
CIVICS MIGHT HAVE KIND OF AN
ALLURE ON THE SURFACE.
BUT WHEN YOU DIG INTO WHAT THEY
ARE ACTUALLY PROPOSING AND THAT
LEGISLATION CUTBACK OR FOR CRT
YOUR MUCH ANY OTHER NIGHTMARISH
IDEA YOU CAN THINK OF.
>> Speaker Gingrich: LOOK, THAT
BILL IS CRAZY.
NO REPUBLICAN SHOULD BE FOR IT.
AND AS MANY REPUBLICANS AS
NECESSARY SHOULD GUARANTEE
FILIBUSTERED IN THE SENATE AND
NEVER LEAVE.
THAT IS THE KIND OF WHICH GIVES
THE WASHINGTON BUREAUCRATS THE
ABILITY TO IMPOSE ON LOCAL
PARENTS AND LOCAL FAMILIES
RADICAL VALUES.
AND I'M FRANKLY ASTONISHED THAT
ANY REPUBLICAN WHAT AGREED TO
COSPONSOR THAT BILL AND I THINK
IT IS AN OPEN INVITATION TO
FURTHER CREATING TOTALITARIAN
LEFT-WING MINDSET WHERE THEY ARE
GOING TO TELL US HOW WE THINK WE
SHOULD BEHAVE, HOW DOES WHAT WE
ARE ALLOWED TO DO.
IT IS TOTALLY WRONG.
I WAS SHOCKED TO DISCOVER IT WAS
INTRODUCED AND I CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT THE HANDFUL OF REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE CURRENTLY COSPONSORS
WILL WITHDRAW THEIR NAMES AND I
HOPE FOLKS BACK HOME WILL CALL
THEM AND DEMAND THAT THEY
WITHDRAW TO PUT NAMES.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM PRINCETON TODAY
ON MSNBC WHEN ASKED ABOUT
JUNETEENTH.
>> WE SEE EXTREMIST FORCES ON
THE RISE TRYING TO IN EVERY WAY
UNDERMINING OUR DEMOCRACY.
ANTI-CRT MOVEMENT.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND THAT REPLACE --
LIGHT REPLACEMENT THEORY.
THEY GO HAND IN HAND.
WE SAW IT.
AS JIM CROW WAS TAKING THOSE.
>> Laura: HOW IS THIS NOT
RACIST?
>> Speaker Gingrich: OF COURSE
IT IS BRACES.
MOST OF THE RACISM IN AMERICA
TODAY IS ON THE LEFT AND FRANKLY
REPLACEMENT THEORIES A TOTAL
LIE.
VIRTUALLY ALL OF US FAVOR LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
VIRTUALLY ALL OF US AGREE WITH
REVEREND MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.,
SAID IT IS THE CONTENT OF OUR
CHARACTER, NOT THE COLOR OF OUR
SKIN.
VIRTUALLY ALL OF IS NO THAT THE
BIKE TIPPING OVER IN DELAWARE IS
A PRETTY GOOD REFLECTION OF THAT
WEIGHED THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TIPPING OVER.
WE JUST DID A POLL WHERE 87 OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE JUST SAID
THAT THEY WANTED TO RESTART THE
AMERICA THAT WORKS.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS
GOING TO CREATE NOT A RED
TSUNAMI BUT A RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE TSUNAMI AS YOU SEE
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS,
INDEPENDENTS, ALL COMING
TOGETHER BECAUSE THINGS SIMPLY
ARE NOT WORKING.
YOU LOOK AT THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING.
YOU LOOK AT THE PROBLEMS ON THE
BORDER, ON THE BORDER TAKE A
LOOK AT THE GEORGE SOROS EFFORT
TO CREATE A PRO CRIMINAL CLASS
OF DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
EVERY TIME YOU TURN AROUND, YOU
REALIZE THAT LEFT REPRESENTS AN
AMERICA THAT WILL FAIL AND THE
ONLY ANSWER TO THAT IS THE
EMERGENT PEOPLE.
>> Laura: NEW THERE WAS A
TYPICAL PIECE IN THE NEW YORKER
THAT CAME OUT ON RON DeSANTIS.
ONE PART OF IT I THINK PERFECTLY
ILLUSTRATED WHY SO MANY GOP
VOTERS HAVE COME TO HATE THE GOP
ESTABLISHMENT.
THIS IS A QUOTE FROM THE CHIEF
OF STAFF, THE FORMER MARGARET
GOVERNOR BOB MARTINEZ.
HE SAID OF CONSERVE DISK.
ALWAYS AN ELEMENT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT WAS BAD,
YOU KNOW WHAT, CRAZY.
THEY WERE MOVEMENT
CONSERVATIVES.
AND WE DID WHAT EVERY OTHER
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE DID.
WE EXPLOITED IT.
TRUMP OPENED PANDORA'S BOX AND
LET THEM OUT.
NEWT, THE SUSTAIN THESE PEOPLE
HAVE FOR AT THEIR OWN VOTERS
NEVER CEASES TO AMAZE ME.
>> Speaker Gingrich: YOU KNOW,
LINCOLN SAID THAT WE WANTED TO
PRESERVE GOVERNMENT OF THE
PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE AND FOR THE
PEOPLE.
WE DON'T WANT -- THE ELITES
DON'T WANT TO HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH THAT.
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRODUCED IN
PART BECAUSE THE WASHINGTON
ELITE FIELD.
WHEN HE ANNOUNCED FOR PRESIDENT,
65% OF THE REPUBLICANS IN THE
COUNTRY DISLIKED THEIR NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP IT.
THAT IS WHY THE NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP COULD NOT WIN THE
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION.
RON DeSANTIS IS A GREAT
EXAMPLE.
HARD-HITTING, HARD-WORKING VERY
SUCCESSFUL GOVERNOR WHO IS
MAKING LIFE BETTER FOR PEOPLE IN
FLORIDA.